a strong economic position that's the
claim the Trump White House made amid an
intensifying trade war turned currency
dispute between the United States and
China America's open for business
America is open for business it's been a
week of back-and-forth between the
world's two largest economies on Monday
the US Treasury accused China of
currency manipulation following a sharp
drop in the UN against the American
dollar fulfilling a campaign promise
made by US president Donald Trump the
drop comes following more US tariffs on
Chinese goods last week 10 percent on
three hundred billion products effective
September first China retaliated
announcing its state-run companies would
stop buying US agricultural products
inflicting further strain on US farmers
but on Twitter
president Trump argued the u.s. is
benefiting from the economic tit-for-tat
massive amounts of money from China and
other parts of the world is pouring into
the United States companies are also
coming to the u.s. in big numbers this
is a transformative president who was
going in many places where prior
presidents and both parties have feared
to tread and I think part of that has to
be trade but the trade war has hurt
American farmers already the US
government has put in place to aid
packages to compensate for the billions
in lost sales for products like soybeans
and pork to China functioning we hope to
see fewer acts like this which serves no
one's interest we also hope to us sticks
to the facts and solves the us-china
economic and trade issue more rationally
and practically rather than move further
along a wrong path the White House says
it's still working with China to
negotiate what it calls the right deal
it expects more talks with Beijing in
September Kimberley hellcat al Jazeera
the White House